you like no no I'm gonna do this in fact
you probably didn't even we're in the
middle of it were you even thinking dang
this is going long were you ever
thinking that it was it was until
afterwards like dang that was long yeah
that's a that's a good symptom good I'm
happy about that
camera one is about to start rule I
don't feel like wearing headphones today
Deva
no no like I don't feel like I just feel
like getting her oh like dang no time
for even putting on the headphones
you're so fucking task-oriented
saturated and saturated oh look at these
books they're all different totally
different there's no book like this by
the way I like that book already okay
like remember the book mind games always
talked about it's it's similar this is
probably like more it might be
significant but um mine game was it was
a lot like that I liked it you gonna
clap this thing out
he's on ready to rock and roll don't
look smaller yeah
Pharrell yeah did you are you just
cutting weight right now I'm not cutting
I just I didn't doing jujitsu not as
much lifting and then a little bit I was
think about the city wall I was
squatting fucking heavy sir you don't
squat do you I do oh you do I do like
front it's like but you don't have
fucking you don't have a squat rack at
your house no so I use like kettlebell
stuff and you know like that kind no I
don't do that you don't smile squat back
squat overhead squat
you're not in there just fucking getting
fucking crazy with squats no not anymore
but you do used to write all the troop I
used to fuck no even no after football
apparel one else into lifting even with
jujitsu but oh yeah fucking bad how deep
not as deep as echoing okay
it's called what do you call it parallel
parallel squat yeah that's the official
standard for football okay alright keep
on good
I'm gonna know okay just say okay that's
the standard so this is this is where it
is like this is why I was like you're
like would you have to explain that I
know well at least you know the
difference I do know the difference the
difference between going fucking all the
way down yeah and going parallel yeah
there's a big difference huge difference
a big difference yeah agree hundreds of
pounds potentially you know maybe maybe
between 100 and hundred fifty minutes
depending even that there's a huge cut
huge caveat to huge kind of it to the
point that it's beyond a caveat this if
it's whatever you're used to so here and
do this do this and you can do this
applies to bench squat whatever so you
know how you like right now let's say
like a leg routine is like a kettlebell
routine and then I'll do you know how
you rack the to get almost yeah and you
do squats front all the way down yeah so
that pretty I'm pretty used to that now
to go all the way down as far as you can
in a pretty flexible by the way in that
way if I were to start going just to
parallel right now it would be harder
well that's good because we're going
whatever you get used to in try that
with benches it so when I used to bench
I call it way down and in touch boom and
then you know I got pretty strong in
bench then I see guys they're like you
shouldn't touch you should be like an
inch and some guys were even mind like
two three inches
so let's account fuck that's easier I go
all the way down I'll get the stretch
what that's easier there you're gonna
add a little bounce
so I good yeah sometimes sure but not
all the time even even if you do even if
you doing no bounce you're still getting
a little miles right I mean like yeah no
no you're getting like a little get back
a few pence yeah sometimes sure but
that's not the point the point is I saw
a go tryouts like fuck way easier I can
do more I do my same weight and its
weight you're right you're right because
I am used to doing deep squats for no
long that when I try like the box squats
or whatever but you definitely feels it
feels harder it's harder yeah for sure
you're correct and I stopped doing
squats um it meant out of its like bit
of laziness right because when and this
was like when I was like this old like
when I was a blue belt and I stopped
kind of doing like
a bunch of legs you know rationalize it
yeah so basically but but successfully
so when I stopped it and you know you
maile and I remember sir you always
telling me this like when we'd be laying
down you lay down on the bed it was like
you skipped like day oh no she would say
the opposite she's like look how big
your legs are right now cuz you know
like I have skinny knees you know yeah
yes getting ankles you know like they're
so you don't know you think like maybe
get away stick but one my one my shorts
kind of fall and you see the muscle part
you know it's surprisingly big fall down
fall up up technically well so say
whatever yeah so they fall in reveal so
that's what you say she big your legs
are it's not Michael I'm like yeah
they're huge but I didn't say that but
so later on when I stop kind of doing
like heavy squats all the time and I was
doing jujitsu I could do way more like a
leg like like triangle chokes was way
easier and was strangely like even going
for arm bars and transitioning from the
bottom and stuff became like a lot more
easy Hey look I understand as time goes
on you get better at these things but it
seemed a lot easier so it's like this so
I'm gonna you know I'm not yeah big time
but thing is it's always worked for me
yeah whatever bro alright I still kept
doing curls though so kind of sing
obviously you'll get there got the guns
to prove that one isn't that funny
though how like skipping leg days this
one kind of fun thing to like why don't
they say that about skipping arms
everyone hurts yeah I guess so well I
was singing that's why I was thinking
about this today
wait but because I was squatting I was
like wonderful I was thinking myself
look you never talk about squatting yeah
and I'm thinking myself I wonder if echo
even squats yeah do you because you got
skinny knees yeah is giddy ankle
but see what I mean now you're like are
laughing like why is that funny
I've skinny wrists too I think is funny
that you said today anyway cuz yeah
because you know squats mmm like I was
getting taxed today like I was I was
getting beat down by squats Monday
morning it's hot in my garage the
weights are heavy I was trying to up it
if you ever seen me get up a little too
and a half's then put them on like I'm
just trying to push a little bit yeah I
did that today and all that I was
getting beat down mmm
and I was thinking I'm getting beat down
does wait I was like this is like proof
right mm-hm
like it takes it takes a certain level
of fortitude if you're gonna keep going
I'm being straight up Lily don't one
workout there's one workout like all the
hardcore the big mac cons and all those
none of those are anything to me
compared to like heavy squat day we are
going this is the thing high rep heavy
squats yeah like 20 reps squats I'm sure
you've heard of this workout 20 reps
squats it's it you're doing it what you
use a weight that you can do 10 times
and you do it 20 times yeah yeah no
don't try to well you do it gotcha
and and it's a nightmare it almost I'm
not kidding it almost makes me cry it
almost makes a tear form up in my
non-shooter yeah and so as I was doing
that today I was like I'm gonna shoot
yeah well I'm not gonna cheer up in my
you know I shouldn't have too much
business no Talia stuff to do so so I
was thinking as I was going through this
pain mmm I was like think myself
whatever echo actually does this cuz
this is super hardcore
I'm honored with and and no we shouldn't
because I was actually questioning well
I wasn't like Tamil I wasn't like echo
does this too I was kind of like a echo
must not yeah whatever I was on the grid
so good yeah and and then
in fact as you did squad if you're
squatting the heavyweights like you or
that's that's yeah yeah and I know that
I know the pain situation for sure and
you did give up on them yes I'm in yeah
I mean technically I mean squat and they
come on let's face it that's a macho
thing to be like oh you don't squat I'm
not even that strong that's that's one
of the that's one of the jacked up
things and and it just like I'm not like
one of these guys like I see the guys
that are winning CrossFit right now
those guys are freakin destroy ya
snatching insane amount of weights I
mean the like Ya Ya Ya Ya be you can't
compare it that's like saying fuckin my
mile time suck still abused college
fucking track athletes they're my you
know it's like you you're like saying
you're sucks compared to the best guys
you know that's true but it does still
does suck cuz like I lift weights
yeah don't run I think you're strong
whoa well until the numbers yeah but I'm
not I'm not saying oh you know I'm
trying to run if I was trying to run a
four-minute mile then I'd be saying dang
these guys are so much better than me
I'm not so I'm not saying that oh but
your training training at least trying
to be like a little bit stronger can use
normal what do you what do you walk
around it you wait to thirty years okay
so two thirty squat let's say first set
of ten if you're getting to thirty if
you can get 405 for ten that's like good
good I think
yeah I'd say I'd say I'm if not they're
a little below there yeah that's good
that's a good squat like the king good
like like dang that's a good squat I
said less than good like if I think ten
would hurt me yeah so like so but either
way that's good
yeah so if even if you were to go three
wheels for ten that's still good it's
good but it's like okay it's not
impressive but it's like it's I'd say
that's fine it's not him and that's a
big difference between 405 and 315
though yeah
that's a big difference yeah like like
315 all the way down though mmm
I think that I mean sure you're used to
it good good for you congratulations
but like when I I was like 240 240 and I
was doing four wheels for twelve that
was my first step that's a legit yeah
but it wasn't all the way down into
parallel but you know like I said and
the parallel is always like oh yeah it
was parallel but it's really hard to
tell you know what I mean
well not trying to say you were cheating
but yeah but in my in my set number rep
number five didn't get it rep number
seven was a little bit off yeah maybe
but in my eye if anyone's gonna get the
correct form that's me cuz in football
they care about that stuff you know when
you test and you touring you test your
all you would you do 225 how many reps
did you do that for bench
yeah that's like the big combine yes so
when I was playing football when I
weighed 180 I did 17 that's awesome
yes I was yeah it was the best way you
played football you were only 180 yes
that was your heaviest well I start to
get a little bit heavier yeah 190 maybe
was my heavier wicked fast I I was I ran
for made the same level athlete you guys
are the same he was heavier than me you
guys are the same level like
athletically yeah more or less
he beat me in the 200 meter I beat him
in the 100 meter day even though even
though he was heavier than you uh yes
that's weird that's reversed right to
what the instinct would be yeah maybe
yeah the intuitive thought would be if
you're heavier and you beat him on the
hundred and he beats you on the 200 yeah
what was your 40 time for four seven
consistently like more than what kind of
timer electron yeah well that's life man
keep in mind this is in the 90s oh yeah
yeah I did to 25 33 times after football
day it was bigger though that's awesome
yeah I thought it was pretty solid yeah
I haven't benched in so long I can't
even tell you well yeah I could
seriously right now
like I remember Allen benched in the
wrong car
yeah I'm with you and I bench just to
see how it feel and it's weird to feel
like all stiff and like kind of kind of
awkward really yeah and I could probably
do 225 probably 15 times my major right
now yeah cuz with dumbbells I can do my
first set with 115-pound dumbbells and I
can do 1212 pretty easy like that like
if I were to like go all out I could
probably get like maybe 16 of those
maybe even more with 115 on an incline
tube by the way I don't do flat anymore
until like afterwards you know and flat
is strong you do decline
no remember decline used to be like yeah
you could go heavier because it's less
range of motion and yeah but not never
no I never got into that that's a weird
exercise decline bench yeah but yeah I
think um yeah but the squat thing why is
that funny though I'm not saying just to
you I think it's funny too you know when
it's like oh the girls keeps licking
like you ever seen a guy with big legs
and he can squat and he can clean and
this guy's legit like you kind of have
this like dang this guy's legit but then
he's like weak on top well how come no
he's is that guy
yeah no that's true cuz that's what I
mean let's face it that looks kind of
funny too yeah but they don't they don't
teach that but are you sensitive about
this not enough sensing like well you
laughed pretty hard look I was more
laughing at the whole situation
evacuates skinny that did stand-up right
now stand up right now that did kind of
cracked me up
yeah see how your see how your knees are
will sit up out here like skinny skinny
when we roll like look at your and your
I would say yours are bigger than the
average person right but they're not as
thick as deans walk like grab mine and I
know I have pretty big muscles so mine's
a little bit bigger than yeah you know
what's funny though I have I have
noticed this and if you would have you
had to hypnotize me yeah bring me like
back into into the recesses of my mind
and if you would have drilled down into
the recesses of my mind under hypnotism
hip under hypnosis you would have found
and you'd have said what is an
interesting characteristics
characteristic of echoes ankles when you
ankle lock them I've been like oh yes
that little skinny ankles and when I
just looked at them I was like oh that's
right I remember that yeah cuz when I
don't I don't go for your feet a lot
yeah but I remember when I have gone
form up in like oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
the resistance and I felt bad feel bad
or not bad but for myself you know
you know guys yeah like Dean I'm like
trying to do a fucking straight foot
lock on a man you do the laughs that's
yeah and I'm like freaking why can I do
that bro Dean is a fucking mutant yeah
all right let's record this shit still
not gonna do squats